[Music]
howdy friends welcome back to the
building of our homestead for the
chicken coop I think I've decided it's
probably gonna be a chicken palace build
today we'll focus on putting up the wire
mesh on the windows and the tops and I
think if we work hard enough we could
probably get the siding up let's get
started come on
[Music]
so on this coop as you may have noticed
it's gonna be kind of an open design a
lot of little research I've done says
that the open coops are kind of work a
little bit better especially because we
live in a very warm climate rarely do we
get freezing and if we do have you know
some freezing weather coming up we can
just put some tarps over the front but
we are going to do wire mesh along the
top and the sides up in there the
research that I've been doing says that
ventilation is key
vanillite vanillite ventilate and the
more ventilation you have the drier it's
gonna be and the healthier your chickens
will be I guess a moist damp chicken
area is not really very good we are
going to put siding here just to keep
any critters or anything that might want
to try and get in there give them a
harder time and then also the wall that
we built extends a little bit past the
entry and that's going to be to kind of
help the wind from whipping in and
around just wanted to give you an
overview on why we're doing more of an
open style instead of just a sealed in
tight type but yeah let's uh let's cut
some wire and get that up
[Music]
you got to be careful when you're
cutting the wire at an angle see if
it'll focus those points are razor sharp
needle sharp it got me already all right
finally we get to the sighting portion
of the chicken coop I went with concrete
sighting 4x8 sheet of hardy board is
what it's called around here grooved
it's cheaper that way for some reason
the advantages of running concrete
sighting is it's not going to rot like
wood siding one disadvantage though it
doesn't have much shear value to it so
it's brittle so it's not going to it if
the building moves too much it does have
the chance of breaking so when we move
it which it's going to be moved I'm
gonna have to take a couple precautions
to make sure it doesn't break too easily
but like I said it's not gonna rot
especially up against the elements that
it's gonna have here with the chickens
and their business and stuff inside
there but it's comparable to a wood
siding in cost but you got your
advantages either way so that's what I'm
gonna do it first
prep the wall for it to make it a little
bit easier
it is extremely heavy so yeah so I want
to have this sighting hanging down below
the floor so I made a mark below the
flooring an inch and a half and I'm
putting in this ledger board and it'll
hold the side I'm doing this alone and
that's really the easiest way to do it
by yourself even if you're using wood or
or other things like that
so I'll just put this on put a screw on
one side and then level that across I
guess another thing I should mention is
it's really dusty
[Music]
[Applause]
so got the siding on the sides and then
the back before I finish up the back
upper part I wanted to show you what I
got going on here what I did is I had an
old above-ground pool that was holy and
wasn't really doing much pooling and I
cut cut a section off of it and put it
over the nesting boxes here and then
once I get the siding on I'm also gonna
do the siting here we'll put a piece of
plywood over this and then with some
hinges but this should keep this area
dried off and looking fresh pretty much
all I did was just put some roofing
nails in right there
basically that's all it's doing and then
overlap my siding looks about three
inches and I'm not putting any nails
down here because I want to keep the
unholy yeah
all right so yeah also on the side we'll
put siding on that little section right
there and hopefully get some trim going
down and it'll cover up that gap there
yeah that's what's going on in the back
time to get back and putting siding on
[Music]
[Applause]
what does chicken say what does the
chicken say you like the chicken house
[Music]
you know